Now that we know how to
hijack a request and
respond with something basic,
let's do something cooler.
Let's go to the network for
the response, but not for
the thing that was requested.
Handily there's an API for that, Fetch.
Fetch let's you make network requests and
let's you read the response.
Now you might be thinking, isn't
this what XML HTTP requests is for?
No, just no.
Much of the XHR API is 15 years old.
Soon it'll be old enough to drink.
And i can't even bare to think
of what a drunk XHR could do.
Even from the outset,
it wasn't particularly well thought out.
I mean, just look at the name, XML, no,
it deals with many
different response types.
HTTP, not really, it deals with
other protocols such as file system.
Request, actually the returned object is
like a strange mixture of request and
response, and why is the XML in
all caps but only the H in http.
But it's not just the name that's wrong.
Here's the code to fetch
some Jason from URL food.
Everything feels like
it's in the wrong order.
The URL's down there you have to
open and then send for some reason.
It makes you declare how the response
is read before you make the request.
And it doesn't support lower
level things like streams.
But worst of all, the event system
gets event to callback hell.
Here's the fetch code for
the same operation.
Fetch foo, this returns a promise
which resolves to a response.
Then we can read that response's JSON.
And then we've got the result.
We can catch errors from either the
request or reading the response, done.
And as it turns out, back in our service
worker event.respondwith takes either
a response or
a promise that resolves to a response.
Fetch returns a promise that
resolves to a response.
So they can post together really well.
So let's respond with a fetch for a GIF.
Over in the browser, let's enable
force update, hit refresh, and
we've just served up different
content using the network.
The fetch API performs
a normal browser fetch.
So the results may come from the cache.
That's a benefit in this case,
as we want the GIF to cache as usual.
Of course we might not
want to hijack every URL.
We could, wait a minute we have
an incoming communication situation.
>> It is I Mike Wales.
>> Hey Mike, so
what's the meaning of this interruption?
>> Well it sounded like you were just
going to describe a load of stuff.
But I think it'd be better if
the students figured this out for
themselves.
>> Great idea, go for it.